LEGENDARY INTERVIEW WITH CREEPY
PORN LAWYER, MORE OF IT COMING
UP.
HE’S ACTUALLY OUT OF JAIL IN
HOME CONFINEMENT.
BUT FIRST IT’S BEEN A TUMULTUOUS
WEEK FOR THE WASHINGTON
REDSKINS.
FIRST THEY CAME TO THE MOB AND
CHANGE THEIR NAME AND 15 FORMER
EMPLOYEES SAY THE ORGANIZATION
IS A TOXIC WORKPLACE FOR WOMEN.
REPORTER DAX HOLT HAS BEEN
FOLLOWING THE STORY AND HE JOINS
US NOW.
THIS LOOKS TERRIBLE.
>> IF THIS IS A PRETTY SERIOUS
STORY, THANKS FOR HAVING ME.
BASICALLY THE WASHINGTON
REDSKINS OWNER DANIEL SNYDER HAS
FACED A LOT OF CONTROVERSY.
FIRST THE PRESSURE TO CHANGE THE
TEAM’S 87-YEAR-OLD NAME AND NOW
LIKE YOU SAID A 15 FORMER FEMALE
EMPLOYEES HAVE COME FORWARD IN A
"WASHINGTON POST" EXCLUSIVE
DETAILING NUMEROUS INSTANCES OF
SEXUAL HARASSMENT AND AN
UNHEALTHY WORK ENVIRONMENT.
IN THE ARTICLE THE WOMEN
DESCRIBED CULTURE OF FEAR AND
BELITTLEMENT AND THEY SAY IT WAS
A PLACE WHERE EXECUTIVES BERATED
THEM, MADE COMMENTS ON THEIR
APPEARANCE AND LET THE WOMEN
FEELING HELPLESS WHEN COMPLAINS
ABOUT EXECUTIVES WERE IGNORED.
ONE FULL-TIME STAFFER FOR ABOUT
220 FULL-TIME EMPLOYEES.
THE WOMEN TOLD THE POST THAT
THERE WERE OFTEN INFORMALLY TOLD
BY OTHER VETERAN EMPLOYEES WHICH
MALES TO AVOID IN THE HALLWAYS
AND STAIRWELLS TO AVOID BECAUSE
IT COULD LEAD TO MEN LOOKING UP
THEIR SKIRTS.
AS FOR DANIEL SNYDER HIMSELF HE
WAS NOT ACCUSED OF
SEXUAL HARASSMENT BUT MORE AS A
BOSS WHO BELITTLES HIS SENIOR
EMPLOYEES.
ONE FORMER EMPLOYEE WENT ON TO
TELL A STORY WHERE HE THEY ALLEG
THAT SNYDER AFTER A MEETING
WOULD BERATE ONE OF HIS SENIOR
MANAGEMENT MEMBERS SAYING HE
WOULD MAKE FUN OF THE FACT THAT
HE WAS A CHEERLEADER IN COLLEGE
AND MADE HIM TO CARTWHEELS DOWN
THE HALL.
SNYDER DECLINED TO COMMENT ON
THE STORY AND THEY NOW HAVE TWO
LAW FIRMS WORKING ON THIS.
ONE TO HANDLE THE SITUATION AND
THE OTHER, THE NAME CHANGE.
>> Brian: WHAT KIND OF
REPUTATION DOES DANIEL SNYDER
HAVE BESIDES UNDERACHIEVING ON
THE FIELD AND FIRING COACHES?
>> NO, THERE HAS BEEN A LOT OF
STORIES OVER THE YEARS SO YOU
KNOW, SOMETIMES THESE THINGS
CATCH UP WITH YOU AND THAT’S ALL
I CAN SAY.
>> Brian: THREE EMPLOYEES
ACCUSED OF IMPROPER BEHAVIOR,
ALEX SANTOS AND THE TEAM
DIRECTOR OF PERSONNEL.
THIS COULD GET REALLY BAD, IT IS
LIKE -- IT READS LIKE ANIMAL